this is the 2014 high school graduation
ceremony for leap Academy the school is
located in Camden New Jersey which is
the poorest small city in America
growing up in Canada my family was so
poor I thought it was normal I had a
single mother she had three kids my
father was a homeless drug addict before
I could even walking so I wasn't
supposed to make it out I wasn't
supposed to graduate high school I was
supposed to go to college
leap stands out among Tammy's public
schools which are among the worst in the
nation in 2014 only 61% of Camden high
school students graduated on time and
leap the graduation rate with 98 percent
and every student who made it through
also got to college I figured out at a
very young age that I was tried to be a
wife and a mother and not a baby mama I
would have a career and not a job and I
will own a house next to actual
neighbors and not rent a row home next
to an abandoned building the difference
is that leap is a charter school which
among other things means that Gloria
Bonilla Santiago the school's
larger-than-life founder and chairman
controls nearly every aspect of the
school's operations in a way that a
public school principal never could and
because it's a charter leap only
survives because parents make the choice
to send their kids here
in Camden this is the worse we have the
offer as a society not in terms of the
people but in terms of the conditions at
the same time we have some amazing
schools that are growing out of the
rocks there and doing the right thing
for kids
the most powerful tool that the city has
is families even if the kids were being
raised by brothers and sisters and grand
moms and you know extend the family
systems everybody to love the children
you know they love the kids and I I was
impacted by that there was so much
despair at least its kids you know felt
loved by their families and they really
became my my army in the early 90s
Gloria Bonilla Santiago hatched a plan
to create an alternative option for
families desperate to avoid sending
their kids to Camden's traditional
public schools
I signed though five hundred parents
through an idea she got deeply involved
in building political support for the
state's first charter school
authorization bill when things got
difficult what I called the parents here
I come for the legislature every time
the devel came up in committee there I
was with buses of parents in 1996 the
Charter School bill passed and leap
became one of the first to open in New
Jersey located in trailers on a vacant
lot on the Camden waterfront it was
about bringing leadership leadership to
have the guts to say what matters here
is the children and we're going to
create a school system that is gonna
work
and we're gonna hold teachers
accountable when they tell the union's
hell no you're not gonna run our schools
today leap occupies five modern
buildings in downtown Camden offering
its 1,500 students a cradle till college
education to to the third and then not
only did every kid get into college last
year some are attending the top schools
I get only 70% of the per pupil cost I
can then guess well I get 15,000 per
child Condon gets twenty eight well with
that money I get to pay mortgages I get
to pay books I get to pick teachers
wonderful salaries these are the seconds
squared
it's not just about having things but
also about feeling things feeling
important they mean that you could work
to get all these things everybody else
has all these people want to solve
poverty before you solve schooling
schools or institutions we control and
that's what I feel like we need to be
doubling down I'm there every day every
day
don't let anybody ever tell you what
your life is supposed to be like not a
teacher not your friends not your family
members there's so many things that are
blocking you from getting to where you
want to be but hard work and education
will break through any wall it'll bust
through any glass ceiling there's
absolutely nothing that can stop you if
you invest in yourself that's my song a
lot of children has been killed and I
look at their pain and the hurt on their
faces and I don't want that I don't want
my son to get caught up in the wrong
anything